after the success of the first film The
Muppets return in Muppets Most Wanted a
movie that literally takes place
directly after the first one yeah you
see them waving and saying goodbye and
then suddenly they're just jumping right
into the sequel I love movies like that
if you wanted you could just edit them
together as one big film that takes a
very strange detour halfway through it's
still funny
The Muppets are back at the Muppets
studio but it looks like trouble is
a-brewin as an evil criminal who happens
to look exactly like kermit breaks in
switches them up and now he's confused
for Kermit while the real Kermit is
thrown in jail yeah they're doing that
cheesy story and again even the Muppets
acknowledged they're doing that cheesy
story Walter and a few others start to
catch on and they try to figure out
what's the best way to stop this
criminal mastermind while also getting
Kermit back safely while also convincing
everybody that this guy is not the real
Kermit standard oh yeah but funny
incredibly where I thought the last
Muppet film was very much trying to be
similar to the first Muppet movie this
one is definitely trying to be like the
second Muppet movie a great Muppet Caper
some people didn't really like that
because they like the emotion of the
last film and in this one it's not
really there but it's not supposed to be
there this one is just returning to the
straight on jokes and clever writing
kitschy song numbers and goofy sequences
and they all work honestly my favorite
Muppet film out of all of them is the
great Muppet Caper even though I love
the emotion of the other ones I just
thought the comedy and the creativity of
that one were so great it was just so
spontaneous and odd but also so
entertaining this one I felt the same
way where the first one has some
problems that we overlooked because the
emotional moments were just so good this
one I think has a lot less most of the
jokes hit bull's eyes and a lot of them
you don't see coming and a lot of them
really do try serve a different humor
while also staying to the traditional
humor that the Muppets are so well known
for it's combining old cliches with new
cliches and there's still all those
pointless celebrity cameos and all these
weird song sequences that just come out
of nowhere the music and lyrics are
incredibly clever so I was kind of
scratching my head why people weren't
getting as into this one as they did
with the first one that's to say I don't
know anyone that a
the movie but people were either on and
and think that much about it or it was
okay the only thing I can gather is that
the first film while it did have more
problems took more risks the emotional
moments in the first one could have very
easily bombed or been awkward or just
didn't pay off which would have caused
people to not only dislike it but really
dislike it but because they took that
risk and it worked a lot of people got a
lot more emotional to it and they
connect it as something much bigger than
the other Muppet movies this one is a
very standard Muppet movie it's really
nothing but jokes even the plot is kind
of one big joke for me I don't mind
that's kind of like what the traditional
Muppets were but for others they might
be wanting something more he'll even in
the opening song vague knowledge that
sequels are usually not as good as the
first one to me that makes me laugh but
to others it might be like they're kind
of admitting that they know this one's
not going to be that great and that can
put them in kind of a weird feeling
throughout the rest of the film for me
though I loved it I thought it was
hilarious I do admire the chances that
the first film took more but in terms of
what made me laugh harder that
definitely be this one so I guess it's
kind of a pick your poison
if you're going for more of the mix of
the emotional with the laughs that's
definitely the last film but you're just
going for straight-up comedy this is
definitely the one to check out I loved
it just as much as the other Muppet
films that I know I'm gonna see it a lot
more times in the future
you